Speaker 1: Let's see if we can chat with
a couple of other people. How about Connor
from Atlanta, Georgia? Connor, welcome.
Speaker 3: How are you doing, David?
Speaker 1: I'm doing.
Speaker 3: Well. Ask some. So
I wanted to ask exactly about Biden
running in 2024 for a second term. If. If.
People who because I'm more of a centrist, I
don't really I'm a little conflicted about the
2024 election right now, because I guess
the running up for the Republicans are
is Ron DeSantis. I don't think Trump stands
a chance running again. I don't know if
Biden would be good enough for a second term
to simply because of his cognitive ability
currently. So what exactly do you think on that?
Because I don't I don't know if I just don't
I'm just very conflicted right now for 2024.
Speaker 1: Well, listen. Speculations about
cognitive ability aside, I just don't
think Joe Biden's running in 2024. He's
I don't think he's interested in it. I think he
would have a very tough time winning. He'll be 82.
I just I just don't think he's going to
run. And I know people say, but David,
he keeps saying his intention is to run. Yeah, I
know his intention is to run. And I don't think
he's going to do it. So I don't think you're
going to end up in a situation, quite frankly,
where you'll have to figure out how you feel
about Joe Biden's cognition. I think he's
just not going to be a candidate.
Speaker 3: Well. Well, who do you
think should be the running up then?
Speaker 1: Listen, I think there's a
lot of people, a lot of rising stars in the
Democratic Party. We've talked about Gavin
Newsom's political skill. I've mentioned I really
like Jamie Raskin, I like Stacey Abrams, I like
Jon Ossoff. I think Pete Boudette judge would do
really well now that he has more name recognition.
Maybe not right away. Maybe it's we've got
to wait another cycle or two for him. But
I think there's a lot of really smart people
who would be good in terms of the performance
piece of what it takes to be president.
Speaker 3: What about? It's funny you mention Jon
Ossoff and say favorite Stacey Abrams because I
do live in Georgia. What do you think of Warnock?
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, I think that his his
demeanor, I love him personally. I think that
something about his demeanor maybe seems like
a less obvious when it compared to some of the
other people I mentioned. But he's very skilled.
I just don't think he's yet as skilled politically
as some of the other folks I mentioned.
Speaker 3: Mm hmm. Right. Right. Do you think
we should get a Democratic president in there
who's religious? Is it because Raphael Warnock
comes from a religious background?
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, listen,
I don't I don't know at this point whether
that really matters. You sort of have to
play to religiosity, but I don't think
you have to pretend to be deeply religious
necessarily. It just has to be plausible
that you like you follow a religion.
I think it's going to be less and less of an issue
over time, although still for the evangelical
voters in particular, it really does matter.
Speaker 3: Right. Right. Okay. I see. Well,
that's all I needed, David. Thank you. All right.
Speaker 1: Thanks, Connor, very much. Appreciate
that. All right, everybody,
that's going to do it for today.
We don't have time for more calls today, but
we will in the future. And I hope to hear from
people next time. Thank you for joining me.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.